alright I was trained as a political
theorist and though my work doesn't stay
within the realm of political theory
that tends to be the way in which I
approach questions involving religion
and politics at least initially and so
while this papers argument frequently
deals with rather abstract matters of
theology and political theory its thesis
nonetheless has a concrete relevance to
our efforts to understand the position
of Mormonism and perhaps more
specifically Mormon candidates in Mormon
voters in America today my argument in a
nutshell is that while obviously there
are numerous specific and easily
identifiable historical social and
cultural factors that help explain the
the confusion the consternation and
sometimes even the outright contempt
which the recent prevalence of Mormonism
in the mass media has inspired one
additional factor that shouldn't be
ignored is our political theology now
with the millenarian and theocratic
world views of the 19th century Church
more than a hundred years old and
perhaps never having really been nearly
that comprehensive or authoritarian in
the first place it could easily be
assumed that there's no good reason why
Mormon beliefs shouldn't fit easily into
America's civil religion even as I was
writing this piece my friend and a
scholar that several of you know Nathan
omen published a piece where he
commented that we now have twice as much
historical experience with post
theocratic Mormonism as we have with
post-vatican to Catholicism and given
that historical experience it's
ridiculous if anyone were to believe
that a Catholic like Joe Biden was part
of a subversive Roman agenda his
implication being that it's twice as
ridiculous to imagine such a thing about
a potential Romney presidency I don't
disagree with the common sense of this
argument but I would respond that
one looks closely at at least one of the
crucial components of America's dominant
if implicit religious / some shins and
here I'm thinking particularly about the
question of Revelation and how that
relates to one's embrace of or one's
rejection of the civil order itself one
does see evidence of something that
perhaps at least as much as the history
of polygamy or you know the existence of
exclusive temple worship contributes
importantly to the idea that Mormons are
outsiders and they lack a civil place in
American public life today now regarding
civil religion I mean this is a topic
that's much studied in the scholarly
literature it is in some ways a
catch-all term that covers a lot of
different ways in which religion and
democratic practice interact probably
the canonical description of civil
religion was developed by Robert Pelham
over 40 years ago he posited the
existence of a moral sensibility in
America which depends upon biblical
archetypes and is undeniably Christian
but which also is a lot more ethical
than theological it's more the Sermon on
the Mount than Christ on the cross now
this is the idea that probably most
people who are not paid to think about
these sorts of things probably assume
religious life operates in the United
States insofar as politics is concerned
as a highly religious yet basically free
and individualistic and diverse society
presumably we ought to consider
religious values only in terms of their
ethical relevance and not their
theological roots in practice however
such an emphasis on ethical presumptions
or as Mitt Romney put it in his 2007
address
Texas A&M University the commonality of
our moral convictions nonetheless still
doesn't entirely escape the question of
the theological or ecclesiastical form
that these convictions or these
presumptions take it's an inevitable
facet of human nature it seems to want
to understand the actions of individuals
as if embedded in some sort of
collective established morally or even
religiously substantive cultural order
meaning in other words that a broadly
affirmed and accepted civil religion
nonetheless almost inevitably faces a
popular demand if only an implicit one
for elaboration and codification even if
at the same time we're reluctant to
grant the legal extremities of such the
political theorist Graham Walker in
looking at these realities commented
that perhaps some form of religious
establishment however vague is
inexorable the liberal civil religion of
American history and American politics
today certainly doesn't have many
strongly partisan or sectarian overtones
but it cannot wholly avoid some
theological and ecclesiastical
implications which means that perhaps
it's not so deeply liberal after all now
we can chart historically the form that
this what we might call non established
religious establishment you know this
codification of civil religion has taken
in America Catholicism slowly journeying
through the 20th century towards
acceptance into what Martin Marty
referred to as the public church of our
civil religion in a different and more
oblique way Judaism made a similar
journey as well clearly the the
construction of the judeo-christian
label as a way for talking about this
kind of
implicit religious establishment
nominally prioritizes the act of belief
over any of its particular content but
perhaps it must be added only so long as
that expression of belief occurs within
or emerges from an acceptable church
context so the real question we asked
you simply is Mormonism making a similar
journey into theological acceptability
or can it now this leads me into a
discussion about one of the most unique
elements of Mormon theology namely
revelation it is obviously key too much
of our existence as Mormonism it's just
historically it begins with Joseph
Smith's claim to have not only been
visited by but actually been
commissioned by God to begin a specific
religious movement at a particular place
and a particular time the legacy of that
Commission is continued down to the
present moment where it's an article of
faith amongst us Mormons that God will
reveal his instructions to the leaders
of the church who are sustained as
prophets seers and Revelator's a
religion constructed so as to take its
foundation in the interruption of
quotidian life with new scripture and
new apostolic commissions and to assume
the continuing possibility of further
revelation would not really fit in to
the classic definition of civil religion
because it's not susceptible it's not
amenable to the existing civil order but
of course religion or rather civil
religion in America is a little bit
different from the stronger more classic
understanding of it maybe too much can
be made as Nadelmann suggested of
America's historical attachment to the
possibilities of revelations guiding the
church in ways that contravene or act
separate from the established little
order of the United States you know the
idea of building up a separate
kingdom of God the state of Deseret and
so forth perhaps those claims being
historically dated can be ignored and
probably they should be and if in
particular it needs to be kept in mind
that those historical claims themself or
rather those theological claims
themselves changed through history the
LDS Church changed in accordance with
what leaders of the church affirmed as a
revelation from God to do so as
Frederick get accessor at BYU put it the
Mormon God does not always demand
faithfulness over survival when faced
with a conflict with the civil order
that threatened to destroy the church
the idea that revelation was leading us
into creeks a creating an alternative
civil order was set aside this most
obviously in the context of marriage but
also in the context of the particular
economic and social practices of the
church now given this change and given
the long history sense that change we
could assume that while we have many
particular theological views that
distinguish ourselves from mainline
Christianity in the United States the
nonetheless our expression of faith
would be enough to make us a settled
participant in America's civil religion
the theocracy is gone in other words we
accept the civil order as it exists
however you can take a look at some of
the data that for instance has been
taking a look at by Robert Putnam and
David Campbell and dave talked a fair
amount about this yesterday it's pretty
conclusive that Mormons are by no means
outliers to the strong civil
contributions that members of religious
communities in America make to the civil
order but Mormont's also have
exceptionally high levels of affirmation
in response to questions
about the absolute truth of their church
and about of their of our church and our
moral beliefs and the correlated high
levels of religious exclusion and
homogeneity which a lot of people would
argue can only have negative
consequences for one's ability to
contribute to a place in a pluralistic
civil society now such exclusiveness of
course is hardly unknown in American
life I'd be very interested to see
measurements of exclusiveness and and in
group affirmation and social homogeneity
amongst for instance a member of an Old
Order Amish community but then again we
don't have a member of an Old Order
Amish community running for the
presidential nomination of a major
political party and so we're faced with
this issue that deserves to be pondered
about is there something about Mormon
existence in America today that leads it
in some ways to present itself to
experience itself as exclusive from as
distinct from the broader civil order I
think that there is I don't think that
it's a drive to create theocratic alee a
different civil order but I do think
that there is an element in our beliefs
there's an element in our religious
practices that encourages even perhaps
unknowingly this sense of separation and
difference at this point in my paper I
go into a discussion of revelation in
Mormon theology and I rely heavily upon
the work of Terrell Gibbons and his
study of the Book of Mormon the upshot
of that part of my paper is a
consideration of the fact that for most
ordinary Mormons revelation exists as a
form of confirmation it is reading the
book of mormon it is accepting a calling
it is
interacting with other members of our
congregation and feeling confirmed in
the truthfulness of our action in
receiving some sort of spiritual witness
that what we are doing is something that
is putting us on the right path I worked
through this for several pages in my
paper and it occurred to me when I was
done I didn't need to go through all
that because all I needed to do was
simply stand up and say testimony
meeting to those of you that are
unfamiliar with this once a month in
Mormon congregations were invited to
stand up and speak to our fellow
parishioners about the truth that we
have experienced in our lives the truth
that we feel in regards to the leaders
of the church in regards to the Book of
Mormon in regards to that which we have
discovered as we have struggled through
any number of different obstacles or
conflicts or downturns in our life it is
a ritualized regular and sometimes
deadly boring but sometimes also deeply
inspiring practice of testifying as to
the fact that we have the truth or at
least we have some sort of truth and
that we're among other people who also
have the truth or have some sort of
truth and isn't this wonderful maybe
that's a little bit of a cynical reading
on the testimony feeling the testimony
MTG experienced but I think the fact the
matter is is that when Putnam Campbell
note that no religious group in America
feels warmer towards their own group
than Mormons then what you are seeing is
a theologically driven practice in the
modern Church that makes us almost rip
that makes us almost replicate an
ethnicity Putman Campbell also you know
to try to account for this
they you know talk about the Mormon
experience with persecution they talk
about in group migration they talk about
geographic concentration and all those
things I think are obvious variables but
I think it also has to be considered the
fact that the way that we have developed
our teachings of Revelation we feel as
though revelation is something that is
experienced dialogical II to use a term
that Givens makes use of in
correspondence with ourselves with other
people who are also experiencing the
same sorts of confirmation of truth this
sort of in-group affirmation this sort
of thinking this sort of collective
experience of knowingness of God's love
for us and the fact that we know that
he's given us the truth becomes very
very important for trying to understand
the ability of Mormons to effectively
create bridges to those of other groups
it's very significant in trying to think
about the way in which we will even talk
about our beliefs when engaging with
other Christian churches when friends
since we've as Mitt Romney has tried to
make an effort to situate ourselves
within this vague religious
establishment this mainline civil
religion within the United States Fred
get x also made the comment that there's
a certain discourtesy in a liberal
society in expressing broadly and
publicly that one's religious beliefs
are universally applicable and
absolutely true now I think most Mormons
know this and the problematic issue is
not some sort of hypothetical rudeness
Mitt Romney himself acknowledged in his
faith in America speech that we're of
the affairs of our nation are concerned
it's usually a sound rule to focus on
the great moral principles that urge us
all on a calm
of course but the common course is the
rub there how is that course charted how
is it elaborated and expressed not
through theological argument or dr. Lee
demonstrating one civil religion bona
fides at least not primarily in fact the
argument could be made that you know as
a presidential aspirant Mitt Romney has
been put into kind of an impossible
situation simultaneously trying to
appeal to portions of the Republican
electorate that his beliefs make him as
much a part of the mainline civil
religion as any other Christian while at
the same time insisting upon the
importance of toleration within
America's were liberal society you know
basically trying to fit himself into the
civil religion but also emphasizing
toleration for those who don't fit in at
the same time this kind of difficulty I
is I think exacerbated when you are
looking at a church culture to with
church practices with you know ordinary
Mormon life organized around these
affirmations of the truthfulness of the
Mormon faith and when obedience to
Central Church directions and the
resulting homogeneity and exclusion
despite its negative social consequences
is often dialogical II received amongst
ourselves in testimony meetings and in
our own correspondence with each other
as a further confirmation of that truth
I'm the parent of a teenager and I hear
all the time I hear coming out of my own
mouth sometimes statements along the
lines of well you know the fact that you
couldn't go to that party or the fact
that you couldn't date that person and
the consequent feelings of isolation or
social exclusion that you're
experiencing from that that's a good
thing that's a true thing because that
experience
that you know you know feeling of
separateness from you know the civil
life that pertains at your high school
or wherever is in fact a witness to you
that God has put you on the true path
now I'm elaborating it in a much more
theoretical way than I think I would
ever speak it to my daughter or at least
I would hope so and it's and it's unfair
i think a little bit to to build out of
you know the testimony bearing
experience you know all of these kinds
of civil implications you know certainly
when people talk amongst themselves
about the fact that well you know I I
missed out on that promotion because I
felt it was important that I don't work
on Sunday and this is a harm to my
family but I know it's a good thing
because it's enabled me to you know once
again feel in this sharing of this
suffering of myself with other people a
sense that I'm on the right path it's a
little bit unfair to take all of that
and build from it you know the fact that
Mitt Romney sometimes stumbles on the
stump and says some on things and has a
hard time connecting in some ways with
people whose beliefs morally and
ethically as well as politically ought
to be perfectly in line with what he has
to say so I don't know I'm not proposing
this as an explanation of you know
campaign difficulties that Mormon
politicians are inevitably going to face
i present it in kind of an ideational
sort of way something to ponder about
Mormons really strongly believe that
they are members of the only true church
on the face of the earth and they say
that to each other a lot because they do
that and because their theological e
driven to do so because you know I it
you know believing what I do
feel kind of theological you bliged
often to say those sorts of things
that's going to have a certain effect on
my ability to situate my own faith in
comparison with other denominations now
I don't doubt that there are true
believers amongst all of the other
churches that make up America's mainline
civil religion but as has been
demonstrated none of them seem to say
these sorts of things as often to
themselves as we Mormons say it to
ourselves and so let's ponder that as
one theological variable at work in
trying to figure out why mormons in 2012
despite the fact that the great majority
of American Mormons are entirely in line
with the same sorts of conservative
views that are expressed by much of the
mainline Christian establishment in the
United States nonetheless runs into some
of this confusion and consternation
sometimes you maybe it's not maybe the
theological problem is not what our
beliefs are but it's rather the way that
we talk about them thank you